our Series a more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as Americans is
far greater than what divides us this
morning we're introducing you to a group
that's teaching young women and girls to
find their own voices through the arts
CBS this morning Saturday co-anchor
that's Dana Jacobson has this very
inspiring story Dana good morning good
to see you good morning good to see you
too Gail it is called girl be heard part
acting part activism the program reaches
young women and girls ages 11 to 21
through a traveling company a free
after-school program also weekend
community programs the group's
philosophy is to encourage the next
generation of leaders through the power
of performance you are not his trophy
you are not everyone's best wishes you
are your own Alisa Martinez's love for
poetry and performance inspires her to
create art with a purpose the 20 year
old is a mentor for girl be heard a
theater collective empowering young
women and girls through the Arts it's a
pleasure honestly to introduce those
things to other girls from my community
everyone needs a role model everyone
needs someone that they can be
vulnerable with and say like I want to
talk about this or I'm not sure about
this part of myself I want my words to
open doors that have never been opened
before getting them to be comfortable to
do anything and say anything around
others Kym Sykes is the program's
artistic director girl be Hertz mission
is to develop amplify and celebrate the
voices of girls through socially
conscious theatre making we have girls
from all walks of life some come in they
want to be leaders some come in they
don't have any idea what they want to do
it feels like so empowering to be there
Madison Clark Jenaya Pompeii and
Persephone leontes all seventh graders
say being in the girl be heard after
school program has helped them gain more
confidence and self-esteem I think the
little exercises have a bigger lesson to
it you really break it down you can
understand it
that's my gender but I'm really human a
safe space to talk about difficult but
important topics consent definition my
permission for something to happen my
agreement to do something and that's
what you needed why do you think a poem
has made you feel comfortable with an
issue like consent there's people who
don't understand it and they cross that
line and if you hear a poem about
consent you realize what consent is or
like what it can be but what it isn't
that's like really it makes more sense
when you understand what it is and what
it isn't
did you ever think that performance or
art could be that powerful yeah we were
talking about depression how girls are
coloring more likely to have depression
when people like young girls speak about
that it'd be like oh like I'm not the
only person dealing with this somebody
else that could be done with that up
there too so these performances be it a
song or a poem or a story are helping
you to realize that you're not the only
one dealing with some of these Roby
herds message has reached audiences from
the UN to the White House why is it
important that girls be heard I think
that it's important that girls are heard
because we have such powerful voices and
it's more than just a girl talking it's
someone who's powerful enough to say
they say how they feel and make it stick
as long as I'm comfortable with it and
I'm like fill a thousand percent with it
nobody can tell me anything and that's
what this group makes me feel amazing
Madison had that yes and what Bethenny
was saying was that she didn't
necessarily in the beginning but it was
coming out in her it's just so important
for them to know they are not the only
ones with these feelings going through
these issues and it does give them a
safe space to discuss and bring into a
global world as well as so when you
write all this out it gives you a place
to put it and to to give it power in
effect yeah in New York right now but
certainly it's something you'd love to
see go nationwide
yes but Dana I love that they're
learning this in seventh grade
seventh-grade you're 11 12 13 yeah then
you can be that confident at that age
and that's when you're experiencing so
much issues that we're almost afraid to
bring to them
sex trafficking consent all of these you
have to them that's the formative time
yeah all right Dana thank you